- My mother who was, we
put her into a condo,
as I could tell her.
Her house all, she's short, so
(Kelly laughing)
all the pictures are real-
- Is it assisted living?
Is that what it is?
- Ah, it's such a long story, so its-
- I just love that you called it a condo.
- The only way I could
get her in it is I said,
"Hey, think of it as a condo."
- And her whole demeanor says,
"Oh, like in Florida or something?"
"Yeah, that would be it
(audience laughing)
except it's in mid-Michigan.
But, yeah, consider it
a condo in Florida."
- But people take care
of you. That's nice.
They play games, they do stuff.
- Yeah, uh-huh.
- Do you feel like it's your turn
to take care of your momma now?
- Well, nobody trains
you how to be a parent,
and certainly nobody trains
you how to be a parent
to your parent.
- Yeah.
- Luckily there's nine of us,
and we're able to move,
all of us are, but it's-
- I forget how many brothers
or siblings you have, wow.
- Yeah, I'm lucky 'cause I
have a lot of good friends
that are taking care of
their parents on their own,
and it's so much.
- Yeah.
- If you're doing it, or you see it,
it's really difficult 'cause-
- Well, it's time consuming
if you also have a job,
and you also have a family until-
- My mother once looked at me
and I've had a good
relationship with my mom.
I've been in a lot of trouble my life
and so she and I have
come to understanding
that none of my bad
behavior was her problem.
I made my own bad decisions.
And I've helped her through this,
but, I've been like a friend of hers
(Kelly laughing)
'cause I listened to
everything she has to say
and I don't give her any advice.
And so, she's mean right
now to all my brothers.
And she finally got mean to me one day.
I was telling her, "You can't do this."
She didn't make any sense.
She's making weird sentences.
And I said, "I don't understand."
"You're calling me a liar!"
"No, I didn't call you a liar,
but the first part of that sentence
did not match the last part."
She goes, "You know what?
Why don't you go to lunch
and don't hurry back."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I laughed at first, I went,
(laughs) "Are you serious?
Did you just say that to me?"
She doesn't know how to shut things off.
And it's a real challenge.
- Oh, my mom,
she'll hate me for
this, she has no filter.
Do not ask my mom for the truth.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
'Cause she will serve it up on a platter
and be like, "You asked."
- But you're not asking for it.
That's what I'm saying-
- No, no, she does that too.
You don't even have to ask.
Yeah, she does that too.